اوكرانيا تحذر روسيا ستشن هجوما واسعا
خلال ايام هاري يفضح شقيقه ويليام بكشفه
عن قواعد ملكيه خرقها محكمه ايطاليه تقرر
منع اجبار الاحفاد على زياره اجدادهم هذه
الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
بالتزامن مع الذكرى السنويه الاولى للحرب
في اوكرانيا قال وزير دفاعها
ان روسيا تخطط لشن هجوم كبير على بلاده
في حديثه لقناه فرنسيه ان قواته تخشى من
مناوره عسكريه جديده واسعه النطاق مع
اقتراب ذكرى بدايه الحرب متوقعا ان القوات
الروسيه ستحاول الهجوم من محورين من دون
باس او من الجنوب واكد الوزير ان كيف
تستعد لهذا السيناري مضيفا نحن لا نقلل من
شان عدونا كما ذكر ان عددا من افراد الجيش
الروسي على الحدود قد يصل لنصف مليون وليس
300 الف كما اعلنت موسكو في سبتمبر
الماضيه
عدا الامير هاري ليتصدر حديث السوشيال
ميديا بتصريحات جديده نقلها كتابه المثير
للجدل وكشف فيها ان شقيقه ويليام خالف
القواعد الملكيه مرات عده ومن ضمن هذه
الخروقات التي تحدث عنها هاري هو ان ولي
عهد بريطانيا سافر على نفس الطائره مع
ابنه الامير جورج الذي يعتبر حاليا الوريث
الثاني للعرش في جوله ملكيه لاستراليا عام
2014 اذ لا يجب ان يسافر وريثاني للعرش
معا خوفا من وقوع حادثه وذكر هاري ايضا ان
ويليام تحدث مع مزارعين في السياسه حول
اثناء زيارته منطقه عام 2019 وهو امر
يعتبر خرقا لبروتوكولات العائله الملكيه
نبقى في الاخبار المتعلقه بالعائله
الملكيه البريطانيه اذ اعلن المصرف
المركزي الاسترالي ان صور ملوك انجلترا
ستختفي من الاوراق النقديه في استراليا
وخصوصا التي ستحمل فئه الخمسه دولارات
منها والاستعانه برسوم تكرم ثقافه السكان
الاصليه المصرف المركزي اوضح ان قراره هذا
مدعوم من قبل حكومه حزب العمال التي تفضل
انتقالا محتملا الى جمهوريه استراليا لكنه
لم يذكر اي تفاصيل بشان صوره الملكه
الراحله الثانيه التي تظهر على بعض
العملات المعدنيه المتداوله
في قرار وصف بالتاريخيه وغير المسبوق قضت
المحكمه العليا الايطاليه بعدم اجبار
الاطفال على زياره اجدادهم في حال لم تكن
لديهم رغبه في ذلك صحيفه التايمز التي
اوردت الخبر اوضحت ان القرار اتى بعد
معركه قانونيه طويله شملت درجات عده من
التقاضي وذلك قبل ان تعلن اعلى محكمه
استئناف في ايطاليا انه لا يمكن اجبار
الاحفاد على اقامه علاقه لا يتمتعون بها
ولا يريدونها مع اجدادهم واوضحت المحكمه
ان القاعده تطبق بشكل كبير تطبق على
الاطفال الذين تزيد اعمارهم عن 12 عاما
وفي خبرنا الاخير اكتشف علماء الاثار حانه
في مدينه لاجش القديمه بالعراق يعود
تاريخها الى عام 2700 قبل الميلاد مما
يشير الى ان تناول الطعام السريع كان
شائعا قبل الالاف من السنين ووفقا لما
نشرته شبكه
لتناول الطعام في الهواء الطلق وغرفه
تحتوي على مقاعد وفرن وبقايا طعام قديمه
اضافه لثلاجه عمرها 5000 عام خائنين ان
هذه الثلاجه كانت تمتص الرطوبه لتحافظ على
بروده الطعام فيما انها اكبر الواقع
المواقع الاثريه في الشرق الاوسط